Hello! Welcome to Unit 5 Office Hours.
I'm Jonathan, an assistant instructor for an upcoming course.
Peter is out of town this week, so I'll be handling the Unit 5 Office Hours this week.
First question, how's that readability survey coming?
It's a great question and relatively timely.
It turns out that readability survey, the research project
that we give everyone a chance to be involved in, is going really, really well.
Over 6,000 people have started taking the survey, and over 2,000 people completed it
all the way through, and the results are still coming in.
Again, this is officially unrelated to Udacity or your grade.
It's totally optional, although it would make me so happy
if you would take the survey--still totally optional.
We have a number of students with no experience taking the survey, which is great.
We have a number of students with quite a bit of experience,
and we even have interesting students who appear to posses the power of time travel
or have made slight typos when filling it at the end how much experience they have.
There are people who have more years of experience in Python
than Python has actually been around--presumably Guido's father or something like that.
We are pleased as punch with the current results of the survey, and I think it speaks to
the charity and the kindness of students at Udacity and elsewhere
who are interested in helping out with this sort of thing.
My graduate student, Jonathan Dorn, and I will definitely be
giving the song reward later on.
However, since this is a family, show since anyone could be signing up
for Udacity classes, a number of the more interesting suggestions for things
that we will sing even though they're more humorous and outlandish
may have to be pushed aside because we, in essence, want it to be rated G at the end.
Still cast your votes for how you would like us to sing or otherwise reward you,
and let me just once again thank everyone who took the time to participate.
I know it did take time, and I know this sort of survey or research
might seem hard to understand when you first get involved in it.
Why is he asking me these questions?
Why is he not showing me the entire context of a function?
Why doesn't he define what readability is?
All of those things that appear to be tricky about the survey or about the study
were set up that way in order to help us scientifically isolate or control for various variables.
It's tricky, and I'm glad you took the time to do it, and I think it will help us out a lot.
We've had more than an order of magnitude more people participate in this survey
than previous similar surveys in software engineering.
It is a really exciting time and it seems that classes like the classes here at Udacity
have the opportunity not just to transform education but to have an impact on research
near and dear to my heart on both fronts.